ouais ouais je suis un professionnel ouais quand j'ai
reçu l'appel pour faire
Sonic c'était vraiment excitant bonjour mon
Chum rural mr.  dr.  Robotnik c'est un
fou je ne peux pas avec ce mec tu es à moi
le hérisson qui était un illégal laissé
d'ailleurs bien sûr c'est un QI de 300 donc il
m'a fallu une semaine et demie pour préparer
Robotnik veut contrôler l'humanité avec
son  machines Sonic est un pouvoir dont il a
besoin pour contrôler le monde non mais
merci d'avoir demandé
oh ce n'est pas bon
je pensais juste que tu pourrais aimer un latte
avec du lait de chèvre autrichien cuit à la vapeur
bien sûr je prendrais beaucoup j'aime la
façon dont tu les fais  Je pense que j'écris une sorte d'
air du temps avec ce personnage
la moustache était ridicule j'aimerais
pouvoir la faire pousser être capable de faire un film
qui ramène un bon souvenir et se
connecte avec de nouvelles générations de gens
c'est vraiment incroyable j'ai été  très
chanceux à cet égard mon sang chaque
sang mauvais je m'amuse tellement
nous avons créé un monstre que nous ne pourrons
pas vous contrôler